à comptter de ce lundi les diabétiques
des ivelines vont recevoir un courrier
de leur caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie les incitant à s'inscrire au
programme sopia un programme
d'accompagnement gratuit basé sur le
volontariat ils vont bénéficier d'un
accompagnement de la part de l' chche
maladie un accompagnement à distance à
la fois par le biais d'envoi de
documents de livret de fiche conseil
mais également un accompagnement
téléphonique relayé par nos infirmières
conseil ils pourrontins obtenir des
conseils alimentaires des conseils en
matière d'exercice physique et même un
rappel sur le suivi de leurs rendez-vous
médicaux André Clébert est président de
la Maison du diabète des Yvelines il est
donc bien informé et pourtant ce service
pourrait lui être bien utile surtout
dans les moment de découragement de
temps en temps c'est difficile de de
dire il faut que j'aille voir le
cardiologue il faut que j'aille voir le
flébologue il faut que ça devienne des
réflex
et avant que ça devienne des réflexes
quand on fait beaucoup d'autres
choses ben on peut oublier et quand on
fait quand on reste seul avec son
diabète alors là c'est encore plus
triste parce qu'on a pas le courage d'y
aller sopia existe en France depuis 2008
il a déjà été mise en place dans 19
départements et le constat est le
suivant les patients prennent mieux en
charge maladie dans les Yvelines plus de
35000 personnes vont recevoir ce
courrier à 50 an en iveline 6000
diabétiques sont concernés à noter que
les enfants n'entrent pas dans le cadre
du
dispositif